we've come to
realize that to go further in physics
you've got to understand how gravity and
quantum mechanics coexist and all of the
work on Gran unification ignored the
force of gravity that was not the way
that people were pursuing the next step
in our understanding of physics and so
to leave out gravity is to leave out an
essential part of the story and when
String Theory came along and provided a
means for putting gravity quantum
mechanics together that was deeply
alluring to so many people because now
all of a sudden you weren't leaving
anything out so it could be the biggest
unification of all and moreover when we
began to study String Theory we began to
see the more conventional Grand unified
theories so it felt as though we can
have our cake and eat it too right we
can put gravity into the story and we
can unify everything